supongamos que tenemos un alambre de 100
centímetros
entonces ahí está el alambre y mide 100
100 centímetros de aquí hasta acá lo que
vamos a hacer es marcar un punto en el
alambre y realizar un corte digamos aquí
después con el lado izquierdo este que
voy a pintar con naranja claro vamos a
formar un triángulo equilátero entonces
éste lo doblamos y nos queda un
triángulo equilátero algo así y con el
lado derecho que voy a pintar con un
naranja un poco más oscuro también lo
doblamos pero ahora vamos a formar un
cuadrado un cuadrado algo de este estilo
vale ahí tenemos el cuadrado y entonces
la pregunta es dónde tenemos que cortar
el alambre para que el área combinada de
estas dos figuras sea mínima vamos a
ponerle por aquí que queremos minimizar
el área vale minimizar
esta área el área combinada bueno
entonces esto de aquí es un problema de
optimización así que nos convendría
tener pues una variable con respecto a
la cual vamos a optimizar vamos a
ponerle digamos x a la longitud del lado
izquierdo si o si hacemos el corte y lo
de la izquierda es x si esto me dé x el
lado derecho mide 100 menos x tiene
menos x y por tanto podemos calcular los
lados de las figuras este de acá tiene
que ser x tercios cierto todos estos son
x tercios porque este x se tiene que
dividir equitativamente en los tres
lados y de modo similar con el cuadrado
nos queda 100 menos x dividido entre 4
100 menos equis dividido entre 4 y acá
también 100 menos equis dividido entre 4
ok ya que tenemos esta x pues nos
conviene poner el área combinada de las
dos figuras en términos de esta x la del
cuadrado va a ser fácil porque nada más
es elevar el lado al cuadrado pero vamos
con el triángulo que tiene un poquito
más de chiste para eso vamos a hacer un
paréntesis acá del lado derecho entonces
este de aquí es un paréntesis
déjame dibujar un triángulo y en este
paréntesis la pregunta va a ser cuál es
el área de un triángulo equilátero que
tiene el lado que tiene el lado él va
entonces nos estamos preguntando por el
área
no voy a poner por aquí y bueno el área
es de un triángulo si sabemos cómo se
calcula verdad bueno sabemos la fórmula
el área el área de un triángulo es un
medio de la base de la base por la
altura altura ok tras la base mide l la
altura no la hemos dibujado pero la
altura baja perpendicularmente hasta acá
entonces esto me de digamos h y de este
modo el área es igual a un medio de la
base por la altura por la altura si
bueno la base es l déjame borrar
para ponerle el y la altura es h ok ahí
ahí vamos muy bien sin embargo tenemos h
y no tenemos algo en términos de l y
sería bueno dejar todo en términos de l
vamos a ver cómo le hacemos para poner a
h en términos de l y para esto nada más
hay que darnos cuenta que esto de acá la
parte de la izquierda del triángulo
equilátero es un triángulo rectángulo si
aquí tiene un ángulo recto y mira
conocemos dos lados este de acá me dl y
este de aquí abajo como es un triángulo
equilátero la altura llega a la mitad y
por tanto aquí mide el de medios bueno
tenemos el l medios y h así podemos
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras a ver
qué nos dice tenemos h al cuadrado h al
cuadrado más el m2 al cuadrado l medios
al cuadrado es igual a l al cuadrado l
al cuadrado jugamos tantito h al
cuadrado más el cuadrado entre 4 es
igual a l cuadrada pasamos el l cuadrado
entre 4 del lado derecho
h cuadrada es igual a l cuadrada menos l
cuadrado entre 4 para hacer estas restas
de fracciones multiplican
aquí por cuatro y aquí dividimos entre
cuatro no hicimos nada pero ya podemos
hacerlo y nos queda tres cuartos de l
cuadrada y además sacamos raíz verdad
tenemos que h es igual a raíz de 3 raíz
de tres luego raíz de 4 es 2 y raíz de l
cuadrada es l así podemos poner aquí el
valor de h y con eso vamos a obtener el
área que buscamos entonces nos queda
igual a un medio de l x raíz de 3 entre
2 x
por por l
ajá si la copia bien y nada más pues
juntamos las constantes y las l si nos
queda a raíz de 3 entre 4 x l cuadrado
muy bien entonces ya tenemos el área de
un triángulo equilátero con un lado
general nos regresamos de este lado
entonces vamos a ponerle que la suma de
las áreas o bueno vamos a ponerle a
grandota valen le voy a poner a
mayúscula a mayúscula que es la suma de
las dos áreas es igual al área del
triángulo al área del triángulo más el
área del cuadrado área del cuadrado y
bueno ya utilizando esto y esto ya
podemos saber cuánto vale el área del
triángulo llenaría del triángulo es
igual a
mira el lado de aquí es x entre 3
metemos esa expresión acá nos queda raíz
de 3 dividida entre 4 por l al cuadrado
o sea por x tercios al cuadrado ya eso
tenemos que sumarle el área del cuadrado
que es igual que es igual a 100 100 x
entre 4 elevado al cuadrado muy bien
entonces estoy acá ya es una expresión
que está en términos de x le voy a poner
a de x y esta expresión es la que
queremos minimizar queremos minimizar
vale entonces lo voy a dejar hasta aquí
ya tenemos la expresión y en el próximo
vídeo vamos a ver cómo optimizamos este
problema